tu manges et madison n'a pas encore
soufflé sa première bougie fait manger
pourtant elle sait déjà comment indiqué
à sa mère que son ventre gargouille
ça a été vraiment un bon moment où on
était fier de l'avoir justement crif ce
besoin là de prendre montré qu'elle
avait faim elle est la maman de madison
a suivi un atelier où elle a pris
plusieurs signes encore aucun notamment
pour encore terminée et couches et fox a
devancé foire à la maison sur une
feuille a4 avec sandra peur ils ont
moins de deux ans ils sont si ce qu'on
appelle des bébés seigneur il fréquente
que l'un des rares cpe du québec à avoir
adopté dans ses politiques
un vocabulaire de signes pour bébé doc
savage à la communication avec les
enfants on comprend facilement leurs
besoins
et se sorte que ça enlève un peu aussi
de frustration chez les enfants parce
qu'il serait mieux comprendre qu on
parle d'ouvrir une fenêtre sur l'univers
intérieur du bébé on demande ce que l'on
veut marie danielle boucher offre des
ateliers aux parents et aux cpe depuis
15 ans oui c'est le chien
son entreprise a développé une centaine
de signes utilisés par des bébés du
canada mais aussi en france et en
belgique
on dit que l'enfant que le bébé finyear
un an d'avancé sur un bébé non
s'ignorent son quotient émotionnel est
élevé aussi selon de récentes études
cette méthode ne retarde pas
l'acquisition du langage si le mot est
prononcé en même temps que le signe joué
par expérience c'est quand les enfants
sont capables de produire le mot
verbalement avec la parole ils vont se
produire de cette façon là parce que
c'est plus facile de se faire comprendre
comme ça qu'avec les listings permettent
même de désamorcer des conflits mais
certains gestes s'imposent d'eux mêmes
mm ce chaos et radio-canada à montréal
[Musique]